[Music]
it never reached the same heights as the
likes of star trek and star wars but
stargate still managed to carve out a
place for itself
in the sci-fi genre where is the cast
today and how much have they changed
over the decades
let's take a look playing the part of
hyper-intelligent egyptologist dr daniel
jackson
james spader originated the role that
was taken up by michael shanks on
stargate sg1
it's spader's character that unlocks the
secrets of the stargate
deciphering some hieroglyphics that turn
out to be coordinates
based on the constellations he agrees to
accompany kurt russell's colonel jack
o'neill and his men through the wormhole
he helped open
stepping on to an arid planet ruled by
the egyptian god ra
who is actually an ancient alien spader
broke out almost a decade before
stargate
putting in a scene-stealing performance
as elitist bully's death
in john hughes classic pretty in pink he
was in danger of being typecast as a
silverspoon brass in the 80s but he
proved his versatility the following
decade
after stargate spader starred in david
cronenberg's kinky thriller crash
and more recently he voiced a titular
villain in avengers age of ultron
nowadays he's best known for his tv work
having played raymond red reddington on
nbc's the blacklist since 2013.
the show got delayed during the
coronavirus pandemic in 2020
which allowed him to spend some quality
time with his youngest son
we'd go out and line up beer cans
on the big rock on the far end of the
garden and
shoot at him with bb guns the character
rah has been featured in numerous pieces
of stargate media over the years
the androgynous egyptian god showed up
in episodes of stargate sg1 and stargate
origins
and also played a part in director dvd
movie star gates continuum
ra's most iconic appearance is in the
first stargate movie however
and that's largely down to the
mesmerizing jay davidson
a dressmaker who got close to tasting
oscar glory after being spotted by a
film scout and a bar one night
despite not being enacted by trade
davidson was cast to the transgender
character
dill in 1992's the crying game two years
before its involvement in stargate
the film was nominated for best picture
the following year and davidson was up
for best supporting actor
the oscar buzz made davidson an
overnight star and the pressure quickly
became too much for him
he decided to quit acting but when the
part of ra came along and the studio
agreed to pay him a million dollars
he gave it another go davidson turned in
yet another terrific performance as ra
in what would be his last major
appearance after appearing in the movie
jiggery pokery he promptly returned to
his first love
fashion indian american character actor
eric avari
has one of those faces that you've
definitely seen before though you're not
entirely sure where
in stargate he plays village elder
kassouf who welcomes the explorers
warmly when they arrive
he's particularly fond of james spader's
dr jackson
who unknowingly agrees to take his
daughter's hand in marriage
avari is one of the few who went on to
reprise her stargate role
playing kasoof in three seasons of
stargate sg1
avari stuck with stargate director
roland emmerich after making his debut
as kassouf
following him onto his next big sci-fi
epic independence day
in which he popped up briefly as a
scientist he landed a far more
substantial role in the brendan
fraser-led action adventure the mummy a
few years later
appearing as doctor terence bay curator
of the cairo museum of antiquities and
boss of rachel vice's character evelyn
carnahan
he also played an ill-fated human in tim
burton's planet of the apes
a lawyer in adam sandler comedy mr deeds
and a hot dog cart vendor and richard
gear's heart chi a dog's tail
among many other things video game fans
will no doubt recognize avari's
distinctive tones from 2014's destiny
and 2017's destiny 2 in which he voiced
master rahul
in his most recent role he played
mysterious biblical figure nicodemus in
the chosen
a crowdfunded tv series about the life
of jesus christ
katsu's daughter showery the one who
gets offered up to dr daniel jackson
was played by israeli actor milly avitor
the unlikely pair fall for each other as
a battle ra
and when his rule comes to an end
jackson opts to stay behind on the newly
liberated planet
if you cut out the part where shaury is
basically given away as a gift
it's a fairy tale ending done sci-fi
style avital was a newcomer in hollywood
when she scored her stargate role
it was just her third appearance on the
big screen and despite the mixed reviews
the film opened doors for her she worked
tirelessly in the latter part of the
1990s
appearing in no less than nine movies
between 1995 and 2000.
her most notable credits from the time
include the jim jamash western dead man
in which she played a former sex worker
and the rom-com kissing a fool
in which she has to choose between david
schwimmer and jason lee
she spent time in morocco and turkey
working on abc's lavish mini-series
arabian nights
then returned to israel to continue her
career at home she still pops up on
american screens every now and again
however
most recently in a 2015 episode of law
and order special victims unit
alexis cruz plays skara kassouf's son he
is heavily involved in the uprising
against ra
but his most memorable scenes are the
ones shared with kurt russell's captain
o'neill
who is still grieving the loss of his
child when we enter the stargate story
spending time with scarra who in turn
sees the captain as something of a
father figure
helps him do some healing while on the
mission cruz made his movie debut in
1987's the pickup artist
a rom-com starring robert downey jr and
molly ringwald
star gates was the biggest opportunity
of his zen fledgling career
and his time in the franchise remains
the thing he's best known for
he has however proven himself to be a
versatile performer over the years
he's appeared in movies like why do
falls fall in love and sam raimi's
dragged me to hell
and he's played his trade on a number of
big tv shows
including er and american family he's
been busy in recent years
both in his personal and professional
life he welcomed a son in 2019
returned to tv in an episode of anna
kendrick's hbo series
love life in 2020 and in 2021 he guests
out on cbs procedural fbi
benin-born model and actor jamaan hansu
is pretty well known these days
but back when he appeared as rasguard
horus and stargate he was still
relatively unknown
he began his career in music videos
acting in tina turner's i don't want to
lose you
and vogues hold on and janet jackson's
love will never do without you
stargaze was his first feature film and
while it wasn't the one that made him a
star
hansu didn't have to wait very long
afterwards to break into the mainstream
the west african newcomer was in three
films in 1997
one of which earned him a golden globe
nod he didn't get nominated for an oscar
for his turn as slave revolt leader
joseph cinque
and steven spielberg's amistad but the
historical drama put him firmly on
hollywood's radar
hansi would receive his arguably overdue
recognition from the academy for later
appearances
in 2002's in america and 2006's blood
diamond
being considered in the best supporting
actor category for both pictures
you are a good boy who loves soccer
school in recent years hans has become a
regular in the superhero genre
working on numerous marvel projects
after voicing t'challa in the animated
black panther miniseries
he appeared as co-wrath and guardians of
the galaxy and captain marvel
a role he'll reprise in the animated
disney plus series what if
he's got some dc characters on his
resume too hansu played midnight in
constantine
king riku and aquaman and the wizard in
shazam
character actor leon rippy played the
role of commanding officer lieutenant
general w.o west
the man in charge when dr jackson
discovers how to operate the ancient
stargate portal
the south carolina native was already a
favorite of emma x when the filmmakers
started casting for stargate
having appeared in his previous films
moon 44 and universal soldier
he would go on to appear in three more
of emmerich's movies the patriot
the 13th floor and the wacky monster
horror extravaganza eight-legged freaks
rippy has only appeared in a handful of
movies since then the most notable being
gore verbinski's the lone ranger
he is better known for his tv work today
having recurred on shows like deadwood
saving grace and the stephen king
adaptation under the dome
he reunited with stargate co-stars james
spader when he joined the cast of the
blacklist in 2016
and in a more recent credit reprised his
deadwood role in a tv movie of the same
name
he would get famous playing the idiotic
harry solomon on third rock from the sun
but funnyman french stewart had a
pivotal role in stargate before he was a
sitcom star
the actor made his feature film debut in
roland de meric's sci-fi adventure
playing lieutenant ferretti he's left in
charge of the second unit when the
soldiers arrive
though he's forced to retreat into the
temple of ra during a massive sandstorm
which of course turns out to be a big
mistake the men under ferretti's command
are taken down by ra's guards one by one
before he himself is captured stewart
made his debut as harry solomon on third
rock from the sun in 1996
and would remain on the show until it
rapped in 2001.
he went on to become a dependable tv
actor appearing in the likes of that 70s
show
ali mcbeal bones mad tv community
and even stargate universe in which he
played a new character dr andrew kovel
he went on to play principal cameron on
abc's the middle
but in recent years he's become known
for the cbs sitcom
mom appearing as chef rudy in dozens of
episodes
he's also in michael lembeck's
retirement home comedy queen bees
scheduled for release in 2021
it wouldn't be sci-fi without some
members of the exploration party being
picked off by the enemy
and that was the fate of derrick
webster's lieutenant brown and stargate
he's with jackson and o'neal when they
make contact with the locals
and he even gets to sample some local
food before he's killed by one of ra's
guards
webster made his debut playing a
bodyguard in 1981's enter the ninja
a low budget martial arts flick he then
appeared in star trek the next
generation a year or so before stargate
showing up in a 1993 episode as
lieutenant sanders
he became a go-to character actor for
roland emmerich after stargate
joining him on independence day to play
the pilot of the helicopter that gets
blown up
during operation welcome wagon mankind's
ill-fated attempt at communicating with
the alien invaders
after this role he joined up with
emmerich again for godzilla in which he
captains the nuclear-powered submarine
uss utah
he established himself as a solid tv
actor in the 2000s
with roles in the likes of nip turk and
csi miami
and he's still active today webster
played d.a jackson holt on ray donovan
between 2016 and 2017
and in 2020 he returned to the star trek
franchise
as a romulan guard in star trek picard
as colonel jack o'neill's right hand man
john deals lieutenant kowalski helps
keep the team together
when they are ambushed by rasguards and
taken the captive aboard
his ship deal was an experienced
character actor long before he appeared
in stargate
having established himself in the early
1980s he actually shared the screen with
curt russell in his second movie
appearance
playing a punk in john carpenter's
escape from new york he went on to occur
as detective larry zito on miami vice
and appearing joel schumacher's the
client
before roland emirate cast him in his
sci-fi epic deal has been seen in
numerous feature films since stargate
usually in a smaller or supporting role
he's worked on everything from jurassic
park 3 to michael bay's pearl harbor
in recent years he's taken to old guy
rolls growing out his grey beard for the
likes of the ranch set western out of
the wild
in which he played an alcoholic cowboy
looking for redemption his other notable
television credits include snowfall
castle rock and the shield among many
others
the actor that plays the lead role of
colonel jack o'neill in stargate really
needs their introduction
massachusetts native kurt russell began
his career as a child actor
signing a contract with disney after
impressing with his performance in
1966's follow me boys
walt disney reportedly dealt with the
contract personally and would remain a
big fan of the young star up until
disney's death
he was already well known when he took
on the role of special ops expert jack
o'neal years later
having fronted the likes of john
carpenter's escape from new york
big trouble in little china and
tombstone in which he played wyatt earp
after stargate russell continued to
establish himself as one of hollywood's
most reliable actors
he experienced what the toronto's son
described as quote a spectacular career
revival
following his turn as a brutal bounty
hunter in quentin tarantino's the
hateful eight in 2015.
he subsequently appeared in a number of
big films most notably guardians of the
galaxy 2
in which he played star lords villainous
father ego the living planet
more recently russell starred as santa
claus in netflix's popular christmas
chronicles movies
and he reunited with tarantino for once
upon a time in hollywood
playing sun coordinator randy miller
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one